this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
Mike catherwood
uh Our Guest our friend of the show our
long time friend Austin local uh not
Austin local but he's out he's out in
the outskirts of Austin on a farm with
70 animals I don't know if you know this
I know you're talking about a man who is
got guinea fowl don't even know what
those are they're Jack turkeys
apparently uh small he's got chickens
he's got goats he's got two donkeys he's
got two Great Pyrenees those are dogs
bring up a Great Pyrenees he's got two
of them they keep the coyotes from
wiping yeah but I like that you came to
like Texas and you did Texas style
you're not like uh you know you're not
in some high-rise or like in the trendy
Community like you came to Texas and
you're like yelling people to get off
your poor well thank you Farms are you
Country Strong yeah and and there's
especially considering how many people
like from coastal towns came to Austin
and they essentially just live the same
life in it's California Street yeah yeah
um no we came to Texas and wanted to and
we admittedly were like LARPing for the
first six months and now I feel like I'm
I can legitimately talk about being a
farmer you you got your skin you don't
sunblock your skin can take the sun you
can take the raise I've never worn uh
good Mexican good Mexican genetics with
that wonderful hair thank you sir
sunscreen's a scam right is it not for
me not for guys like me I get toasty
right I hear a lot of really credible
people say that but I always I always
like to remind myself especially if I'm
gonna say it to a broadcast
I'm so [__] dumb like I am not the
right person to say any of that like the
mercury in it or the I don't know I
don't [__] know I just know that
since I was a little kid I've never put
anything on my skin I don't even like
the feeling of like I can't either one
neither one of you guys both you boys
can sit in the Sun forever you guys got
some dark dark big brownies got a light
yeah got a lot of melanin a couple
couple Browns over a couple brownies now
listen now now I need to know more I'm
I'm fascinated with the idea that you're
actually out there in this heat yeah
feeding animals patrolling your grounds
with your Pyrenees and keeping the
coyotes at Bay are you looking at that
are you eating the animals too look at
that Great Pyrenees that's what he has
those looks like buddy we um yeah hey
everyone does I don't think so oh yeah
most people dogs yeah most people aren't
like oh yeah Great Pyrenees yeah that's
a giant look at that thing but but are
you killing animals too uh not not our
own I killed the other ones that come on
the the land to get my animals like
where we talk about it coyotes most
coyotes and uh I don't like to shoot at
Birds because I'm not I I've worked at
it to be better but I'm not super
comfortable with my accuracy so I don't
want to shoot
before we got the Pyrenees we've only
had them about eight months
um Waylon Willie Brothers uh I I had to
shoot lots of coyotes yeah really but
but dude the birds are they that big of
a the birds are way bigger in my opinion
because coyotes they kind of live the
same way we do they walk on feet and
they have to be on land and they have I
the birds are the owls and some of these
birds are so effective at being
Predators they got one my indoor not the
Great Pyrenees but we have indoor dogs
as well they're normal people and even
the vet said like I don't it's by the
grace of God that this thing lived it
got it and the claws went in its neck
and ripped it and the sound I'll never
forget I mean it's it honestly I hate to
sound like a a big wimp but the sound he
was making when it was attacking him
I'll never we
you know professionals like looked at
the cuts and stuff they think it was
probably an owl do this something out of
[__] yeah dude a Texas big old owls not
taking that's not they take cats people
don't realize that you can see it on the
internet they take cash it's and the the
gripping power and the their ability to
be quality Predators because of their
eyesight because of their patience
because of their intellect and they can
just hide out in the church was the dog
he's like brown and white so I went I
went hunting for squirrels I went
hunting with squirrels with red tail
hawks squirrels yeah you go hunting you
bang the trees they jump out of their
nest I I didn't like it but squirrel's
the most athletic [__] but they
still are these these red tail hawks
would grab them and start eating them
right away they don't kill them they
just start eating they just start
ripping hey what group of guys get
together to hunt squirrels it was it was
my wife thought you guys you guys get
together on a Saturday and hunt
squirrels uh no I don't like it I didn't
like it
a lot of times
they'll be like be flying and all of a
sudden they see a snake and they grab
the snake oh yeah they grab a rabbit
they just anything on the ground is in
anything on the ground is always in
living Terror of birds of prey Birds of
Prey are the silent Killers hey you'll
love this you know how I've been I mean
we're always boys like we're in sync
Community but me and Dr Drew yeah I've
been talking so much because his son
Douglas yeah I love the manager now so I
met with Douglas the other day he's such
a smart you hey dude and he's crushing
it they you know Drew and his wife Susan
have triplets okay and every one of them
is the the type of young person that you
go like [__]
you [__] at like Columbia Vanderbilt
then they like oh I am also like
classically trained violinist too
lawyers rights you know write to blog
post about like esoteric like all of
them and they're so like I love I love
well man Drew Dr Drew is and I you know
it's so hard because especially now with
medical stuff after after you know the
the lockdowns everyone loves to hate on
Drew because he has
a the capability but also like he has
the balls to kind of put his opinions
out there he's also right train medical
now in hindsight he's also right but you
know you just see so much vitriol for Dr
Drew in it and it transcends Beyond like
we're professional we're colleagues
where I see it and I go like oh that's
not fair he's my boy like I see that
[__] and I was like I'm gonna [__]
ring you know and like because I don't
know what the [__] it's the only thing
that gets me to start writing out those
retort texts or tweets and I go you know
what it's not even you might as well it
doesn't help
exactly it's not helping him because
they know if they can get a reaction out
of you but Drew's the there's saltier
the best absolute best and you say so so
are you uh are you a straight up farmer
right now yeah yeah no absolutely I I
in my off time does podcasts but I I
have a fantasy of like I go out I milk
My Goats yeah and then I have a fresh
glass of goat milk I get some eggs I
have my coffee I'm looking at my hands
that's not the reality of farmer no you
hunt squirrels that happens hey man that
happens yeah but on top of that you also
got to think about like the bales of hay
and Alfalfa that go to the sheep and
goat then you got to go down to the
guinea shed and you know let them out so
they can forage at a certain time then
make sure they get put back in the water
water you gotta watch as they're
foraging for for El haco the great the
Great Pyrenees have taken care of pretty
much everything except for snakes snakes
are bastards really yeah because you
can't you can't account for that you
know we're talking about like
rattlesnakes no they mostly snakes out
where we are but they're big they're not
particularly dangerous but they look
gnarly and they eat eggs they'll get
into your Coop and they'll just wipe you
out of eggs and it's like the cartoons
literally like you see the the bumps
seriously yeah it's crazy so snakes have
taken all your [__] eggs not all of
them but yes they'll get in there and
they're so like they're they're the
night
snakes are I respect the game I hate you
but I have to respect yeah
the smallest hole in a in a fence that
you put up the [__] there's some [__]
hey it sounds like you got some Acres
daddy you got some land just under nine
nine acres yeah which is like I'm sure
there's real Farmers out there listening
like oh silly boy but for me I grew up
in La if you had a half an acre you were
Steven Spielberg yeah
you're saying the greatest the Great
Pyrenees keep the Hawks out of the way
too for the most part I mean I'm sure
the get off the pyramid I like it my
wife and I said if if we knew that we
could have dogs like this we would never
have bought other dogs like I grew up
always having dogs but great Pyrenees
it's a whole area more than German
Shepherds or anything like that yeah
name a dog I had a I had a German
Shepherd my sister was living with us at
the time with her and her husband and
they he had a police trained uh German
Shepherd and that thing was amazing this
is different different in that it's not
it's not just the intellect it's a
primal evolutionary like you know how
you throw a puppy Labrador you just
throw it in the pool it knows how to
swim yeah this just knows to protect and
stay by your side with the kids walk
through the it's impossible so are they
protective against uh people too they
don't [__] yeah but and it's like they
sense it like sometimes the other day we
had
um the HVAC guy the air conditioning
fella come out because we were having
malfunction with it and you can't have
it in this weather
um and he came out and there was
something about him they didn't like
white fellas but we have yeah yeah hey
not a racist dog [__] not a racist
English bulldog English Bulldog whenever
a black guy came over he just freaked
the [__] out man I think it's the
English I don't know your dog I didn't
know he's racist I know you said it like
this you go white guy
do your kids like the farm life
I only have one daughter but she she
loves it and then also
you know I've tried to be really
committed to always checking with her
because that's such a wild transition
from being in Venice Beach to this she's
like um she loves the freedom because
she felt very imprisoned by being in an
area where there was so much crime and
there was so much kind of danger
um everything she did she had to check
with us like six times and I'd be like
okay yes you can go to the neighbor's
house but I have to walk you 30 yards
yeah
here she's just it gone in the farm like
and I have no idea like a like a like a
dog she'll just come back when she feels
like it yeah how old is she nine
and she has adventures and she has a
little she'll set up tents and that's a
childhood I know it's great that that
part is really meaningful to me like
she's she she lives like freaking Tom
Sawyer you know and she's going going to
school out here too going to school
she's making friends she is and it's and
it's like that's another thing it sounds
so corny you know like a full-on city
slicker like myself to move to somewhere
with a little bit more space and land
and then to be like the people here are
just so great but the people here and
they're nice kids as well it's a
different thing there's just so much man
you know I know that you got to get out
here but that's my thing to to this like
if you're gonna move to Austin you do
what he's doing you don't move here I
move to the Gated Community right and
it's just LA but in Austin if you're
gonna do it do it man you're thinking
about you you can be a farm boy uh my
kids grow up with animals yeah I don't
know if I'm the guy for that job but
I'll try all the animals gonna start but
I'll try my best
there's no listen this is one thing I
will tell you because I know you okay
there's no [__] off-white there's no
like all of your streetwear all of your
high Fashions go it's kind of out the
door you can save it in the back of your
closet yeah but listen there
mud and just you can't even understand
how you get that dirty and I want that
yeah I'll trade that life I'll trade all
that [__] you're in out here in Texas
you ain't living in it's not plush grass
and Greenery it's a lot of yeah that's
the amount that the one thing you know
in Hill Country it's a little bit more
you get you get Greenery you know
especially in parts of the year but
that's a thing like my wife said she's
from Seattle area so she loves the
outdoors but she likes great and uh some
conifers the Conifer trees especially in
the summer
this part of Texas becomes West Texas
it's just yellow burnt stuff the parts
and stuff still maintain around here
which is nice yeah you can go get it but
our farm our farm is like orange and
yellow right now that's right and then
you guys coming to town a bunch like
yeah yeah exactly like we'll go to the
Mothership or go to see you know bands
play and you know it's like it's like if
you if if Staple Center was downtown uh
Austin right let's downtown L.A we live
in like you know Encino you know so it's
like yeah it's like 35 minutes here's
another thing just funny
because the populations increased
greatly around here
but you know people will say things to
me and they'll be I was I took an Uber
the other day because I took my wife's
car to get serviced and the gentleman
was so nice he's like well I just got to
tell you man this this traffic this this
will kill you because it gets bad around
here and I was like that's adorable
excuse me sir you understand Venice to
Malibu's about nine miles and that's two
and a half hours of your life that's
soul-crushing yeah stop and go exhausted
adorable that they think it's a lot of
traffic I love it it's nice it's nice
because like even a lot of traffic is
it's not Soul crushing no no it's like
shut up shut up what's up fam hopefully
you guys are enjoying this episode of
the fighting the kid we are in Austin
Texas so we're using the drinking Bros
podcast Studio hope you guys are
enjoying it we'll be back to regular
business next week count is in Dallas
all week with Crowder Alex Jones doing
the damn thing so
hope you guys are enjoying the episodes
live from Austin but don't get it
twisted just cause we did in Austin we
still came with the macadamias baby the
house of macadamias you know how they do
Daddy they got the chocolate dipped the
raspberry white chocolate flavored is my
uh Vibe callan's always doing the
vanilla or the chocolate dip they are
the best macadamia nuts on planet Earth
it's not just for the rich it's not just
for Elon and Jeff Bezos anymore it used
to be but thanks to House of macadamus
they're using local farmers over nine
the farmers that they use for these
macaroni nuts they recently dropped the
new house of Academia milk right here
this 100 macadamia nut milk right here
delicious House of macadamias macadamia
that goes right into your coffee all you
do is put this little this little packet
right here you put this in uh some water
eight ounces of water put down your
coffee tell me you're gonna find better
tasting coffee than this has to make
them it's 100 Macadamia goes directly in
your dark dark roast coffee it's the
best in the biz and you get House of Mac
Davis you want to try it cool let me
hook you up they're going to give you
guys and they never do discounts we go
to house from
macadamias.comtfak you get 20 off the
Macadamia 100 Macadamia in your coffee
the chocolate dip nuts you get the bars
all right you get 20 off all that but
also the giving away a box of the
variety pack Macadamia bars you get the
45 Macadamia snack bars one of each
flavor that you can pick then you save
20 off they're giving you that full free
when you go to House of macadamias.com
tfak that's 20% off your entire order
with code tfak macadamias House of
macadamias you're welcome I feel like
the trafficking Alley's gotten better
though we're not in the top five for
worst traffic because people are people
working from home are people working
working from home a lot of people left
yeah it's not as bad but I think that's
just maybe make an excuse me I I think
with uh some of the advents of
Technology like 3D printing where you're
gonna be able to make everything that
you want right there in your hometown
there's all these new things even like
drone technology that gets Goods to you
so trucks and all these things are on
the road as much I don't like that and
let me tell you why because like
certainly the your quality of life in
some regard will improve because there's
less traffic or there's and there's more
ease to to create but like for instance
I was thinking the other day my daughter
heard a song uh I I don't know if it was
like in the Barbie movie or something we
were watching something and she heard a
song that she liked
and
I in five minutes went to some streaming
site found it played it for her then if
you wanted it we could go to iTunes buy
it and not move from the [__] couch
and I thought about one time when I was
in like seventh grade I was watching
Beavis and Butthead with my friend Jason
hell yeah and they played a white zombie
video and I'd never heard whites and I
was like that's the coolest [__] I've
ever heard in my life
we had to get on bikes and go somewhere
we went to Sam goody in South Pasadena
and then had to talk to humans about
where it might be said we found it saw
artwork
paid money if it you know interacted
took it home and then both conferred
about how good the message you
appreciate it more experience and I
think a lot of that gets taken away it's
it's very it was it was the same thing
with my son he was hit those Nintendo
switches now they're so good the
graphics so good but you don't you know
you don't go into like a GameStop or
like a Best Buy to buy games anymore
it's connected to the internet so hey
Dad I want this game Cool click buy
downloads the game in 10 minutes well
what about hologram technology and I was
telling them yeah what the [__] no
Holograms are like talk about Pyrenees
when I can have you right now hold on
but hold on let me finish the story
before we talk about Holograms uh but so
he wanted that game he downloads it and
I was saying I'm like oh you're missing
out bud like me and my boys used to want
a game again we'd get on our bikes we'd
get our money together yeah ride our
bikes down there we'd have the physical
like the copy all the artwork yeah you'd
be so excited to get home and I'm like
oh you to him he's just like yeah I get
it and it doesn't mean as much it does
it doesn't it won't he doesn't
appreciate it right but unfortunately
we're not not going to get it's only
going to get worse what I meant by
hologram technology is we're going to
get to a point where you're going to
look like you're sitting there you're
you so Mike will be able to that's not
good well that's like Howie Mandel the
beginning of the technology is investing
in it you stand in a thing and it's I it
it's so crazy you're right there like
Star Trek yeah yeah it's like with Ellen
DeGeneres where she was in this thing
and she looked like she was there and
she was talking and people came into the
store have you seen that Ryan I want I
want you to know yeah when that
technology is accessible to the general
public yes I'm gonna [__] your ass what
like that's the first thing what are you
saying the digital [__] your
Holograms
that listen to me what Earth yeah as
soon as we have access to that
Brian Callan is getting duped up no
Lube's gonna be right next to me
no no I don't feel comfortable a couple
of straight guys man I saw
bring up the did you see the Ellen's
generous thing yeah we were on Amazon
well remember how we brought up on our
show right I I don't subscribe to it I
guess if you want to do that you can do
that I'm not gonna happen though it's
gonna happen yeah and it's just gonna
happen let me ask you but it's just like
Zoom would you rather have Mike here on
Zoom or in person it's a little
different it's not though because the
energy the human connection is right I
agree absolutely right I agree with you
I just think it's going to be honest and
by the time that comes out you'd be dead
right but here's what's going to happen
I can get in the car and drive I could
just be right here it's like and what
happens is you go dude I gotta do this
thing but I can do it I can do it
virtually yeah it's fine and people who
are watching it are you gonna see the
Hologram and they're just not gonna it's
not gonna be that big a deal you can do
it on Zoom though now not as good I
think well listen it might not be that
big a deal to the people viewing but
trust me to the people creating a bad
products
there's even even from like
think of like really meaningful moments
like really powerful emotional moments
right in the uh in a good way or in in a
difficult way to do okay here's a good
example
think about you two being together with
Joe Rogan sitting across I know it was a
fighter in the Kid episode even though
it was in Rogan studio and Joe's sitting
there and he's trying to convince
Brendan to quit fighting okay imagine if
Joe's not in the room right it's not the
same Brandon was probably like flooded
yes with all these emotions and every
because he's looking at his friend in
the eyes and he can feel that really
good friend is sitting right next to you
right you can't replicate that you can't
it's gonna be it's gonna be a worse
product that's so true you just can't
and then imagine stand up like even how
he's like you do stand up you could be
in you could be in Dubai doing starem
like you but I don't have that personal
I can't feel the energy
I was at Coachella for and now granted
that was 10 years ago whatever so
Technology's probably gotten so much
better but I was at the Coachella where
they brought out Tupac hologram yeah it
wasn't that though but like like yeah
watch watch this uh Ellen thing just
bring this up for a sec watch this it's
really wild this is this she's standing
in a box and it looks
crazy real
now now they're all here and they're
like what now they don't think she can
see her maybe she starts talking and
then she says you're wearing you're
wearing a yellow top watch she goes what
am I wearing
I see oh my God so she's looking at them
I was really she's clearly a hologram
but yeah but it's but did you see it I
went to a studio did you see how he did
it I was like yeah it looks as real as
it gets like it's a 3D thing well the
Deep fakes are getting to the point
where I'm really concerned and I I think
it's fun the other day they got me I was
watching just like scrolling through
YouTube and I saw
um headline is like
Rogan finally opens up about the problem
with the UFC right and I'm I'm like 45
seconds into this video like I can't
believe he's saying that like how can
you pay this much for ESPN plus and not
even get the money you know what I'm
saying and then have to pay more for a
pay-per-view and I'm like this is this
is crazy that he's just gonna go and
this is all fake as always that's the
biggest word of me man but that's also
the the the strike with the actors too
right like the the digital and all that
stuff which is fair if I'm if I was an
actor I could see but to me but and I I
can't speak to how hard it must be to be
a performer and then think about someone
replacing you that's not real nightmare
but
much like we were talking about the the
broadcasting aspect of you sitting next
you can't there's no AI good enough to
to be Tarantino you know what I'm saying
like I think it will I think you will
start to appreciate the standards of
things of people who do something really
well there's there's no you can get an
AI to make a Taylor Swift song okay and
I'm not shooting on Taylor Swift I love
Pop people who can write good pop songs
it's so great but but you can get that
there's no you can't replicate the
talking heads or you know people who are
gonna or Vivaldi
The cream's gonna rise to the top and
it's gonna separate everybody from that
but one of the things one of the things
is that they they want I guess access to
your likeness right so they want to be
able to take your life and not pay you
yeah
they can't even do that with video games
how are they gonna say they can do that
with
virtual shows that's ridiculous yeah
it's not good uh it's you know the whole
thing is very scary because that's a
concern but my wife's an actor right
it's a concern and I sympathize but
above all that like we should look at
the big picture is that if technology
gets good enough where you can have
Joe Biden real believably saying well
Vladimir Putin's a dictator and we're
going to blow him up and it's what we
have to do from the the White House
Press you know Press Room it's like oh
where are we going with you like they
get they get really bad China's clearly
a a a a a a blight to society we need to
erase last night with with Alex and
Eddie and Joe the part of the argument
was that we just didn't know nobody knew
where to look for it really reliable
truth yeah like everybody had a
different idea if you say something and
you make an argument they go well that
where'd you get that from Ah that's that
and so the sources are the the source
that I'm citing is dismissed because we
don't know what's real there's
confirmation bias so if I believe that
Biden's a lizard person I can find a
group that is going to send me
information that confirms that and even
even worse
because yeah confirmation advice but
confirmation bias has been happening
since modern media has existed yeah sure
but what concerns me more is that
justifiably if you're like really
left-leaning and you get some hard facts
about something that contradicts what
you believe in you just go well I don't
that's fake correct and if you're a
super right wing I've seen it happen
before well and you get some facts about
crime statistics that go against what
you you're like well yeah but that's who
who gave you that uh it came from CNN
exactly yeah totally everything becomes
questions although you know what I did
remember I cited that thing I'd heard
this guy talking about how the five
cities if you take all the five cities
of with gun violence the United States
if you take certain five cities out of
the equation we're not California
Chicago for 189 is not true it's not
true it's a [__] statistic and it's
just it doesn't it's not true well
here's what it is and I cited it here's
what is true and this is this yeah I
would love you know if it's I actually
hope it's not true but I I've done a
considerable amount of looking into it
you see gun statistics in America
compared to other civilized what we look
at is like Advanced countries it's
insane it's insane but then look how
many of them are self-inflicted that's
right and you have to bring that into
account and I'm not like I I'm a gun
owner I'm a big believer in Freedom to
own guns in the Second Amendment but I'm
not someone who's like an ideologue
about it but I will say more concerning
to me than dunking on someone who wants
to present me with gun statistics is
like yeah but wait like why are we
arguing there's that many people [__]
eating guns in this country
to me that's not an issue of the guns
that's the issue of the person and the
same thing also try to share my hometown
you guys okay listen not only I I you're
a gun owner aren't you both yeah I'm a
second amendment guy but I will say this
if you take out suicide and gang
violence if you take out those two big
ones those are very big that's the
another thing that I think is like
secretly kind of even more racist than
even people want to give the credit for
in in the sense whenever there's a mass
shooting like like one that catches the
news right yeah
it's always a white guy well it usually
will be but but and then there's this
debate that it heats up and every the
view to you know Rachel Maddow
everyone's talking about this and how
it's the guns or it's mental and I was
like in the time that we've been talking
about this four black guys are dead in
Oakland or Baltimore and and I was like
you really now want to talk about the
the mass amount of gun violence because
there was this publicized shooting at a
concert or school or something which is
a travesty bit but let's really look at
the gun problems outside Chicago is
people of color in certain cities
shooting each other Dan Dan Holloway you
you probably know a lot about this I
feel like I do yeah can you give us some
insight on on that because every time I
talk when I talk about guns I'll get a
dude like you who will educate the [__]
out of me because what happens is you
and I'll have these things I'll be like
well gun control reasonable gun control
we step background checks and then I'll
get people who really understand the
debate and they're on the they're on the
Second Amendment side and I get schooled
so I'm a little bit of saying having
background checks not Pros I'll go
through these in the order that you
brought them out so the first point is
that um the vast majority of gun
homicides are suicide right that's
correct it's like 65 percent
um Jesus he's like seriously I'm sorry
to interrupt you sir but like put that
into consideration there's that many
[__] people killing themselves with a
gun and that would be that's a larger
issue of depression mental health Lost
family all that stuff and I mean this
with with the utmost respect but you
know how many what percentage of those
of that 65 is [__] veterans a lot
it's it's [__] brings a tear to your
eyes you really look at it yeah it's
quite a few and it's it's also uh mostly
well it's almost entirely men it's all
right as well so very few women shoot
themselves to the other point about
um
the racism aspect I think you're I've
said that for years right so we we spend
most of our political Capital talking
about
so-called assault rifles which is not
even a real thing but let's say it is
right we talk about rifles that I think
they account for less than two percent
of all gun homicides like hammers kill
more people than rifles yes than AR-15
success right and I think about 69 of
gun homicides that are not suicide are
committed by handguns in inner cities
right so we have problems it's there's
there's certainly a problem there here's
here's the thing the last thing you said
about background checks
I I think that everybody who can hear
the sound of my voice right now probably
knows somebody that should not own a
[__] gun right yeah we all know at
least one guy yeah
but who are we going to put charge of
you know deciding who that is the state
the government
before you do that with cars though
dude do you want to give the government
that control yeah [__] yeah we do that
car is not a constitutionally protected
right either right yeah who's going to
dictate whether you're healthy or not
for a gun that's a huge difference
could you say hey if you're on
antidepressants you're not allowed to
have a gun if you're if you're on
certain medications it does cause a red
flag where you're gonna have to take you
can't just go by AR-15 uh well who
decides that you know that's it's who
decides it is the question that's a
tough one because do you know how many
you know how many cops and veterans are
on ssris to deal with the life they live
so that's what you can't say it right
yeah well you gotta crack a few eggs
make an omelette no I agree with you
when you how you define not only Mental
Illness but who decides whether or not
you're actually a dangerous Society or
danger to yourself that's the biggest oh
we do know that do you want to give them
because you know if you give the
government an inch they take a mile so
then all of a sudden they get in and I I
would say this we do have a spree
shooter problem there are that's an
issue that all of us agree on what you
do about it is a lot right now we don't
really have a solution
when you say you have a spree shooter
problem you know you're more likely to
die in your Uber to the airport in order
to die by a spree shoe that is true so
where do you want to put your energy
here's okay here's another aspect that
we have to look at though
I I am I will say outright I grew up
like completely sheltered very uh nice
affluent uh neighborhood in in Los
Angeles and the east side of Los Angeles
both parents in the household loving
environment I'm not trying to present
myself as some like gangster tough guy
but you did but you did math but because
that's because you're exactly right
because of drugs uh because of meth I
hung out with a lot of
neo-nazis in [__] the high desert and
tons of time with like legit cholos like
legit gangsters Crips I would go buy
crack in in nor in like Altadena these
guys were legit gangsters okay and every
one of them had guns every one of them
had
illegally obtained guns none of them
yeah it had to go with any type of
background check and I would love to see
the statistics of this like inner city
violence that makes up a lot of this uh
these shootings they're probably like
these the old-fashioned uh term was a
Saturday night specials right these like
low-grade handguns that are
stolen or illegally obtained it's not
like like you can of course who doesn't
want to invest time and effort into
looking who's legally obtaining guns
that's a that's a reasonable thing to
say but the majority of gun violence
isn't probably committed by these people
who are gonna go get a background check
in the first and that's the problem like
I don't think there's a there's clearly
not a simple answer a solution there's
also more guns than there are people in
the United States so I don't think it's
a problem they can solve I agree I agree
what do you use to shoot doubts what are
you what are you working with uh for the
coyotes yeah I because I only have I'm
not like uh uh uh I don't have a wealth
with guns I have uh two uh 30 out six of
308 that I've used for hunting and I
realized very quickly like I shouldn't
be shooting coyotes with that yeah
because a friend of mine who lit was
born and raised in in kind of like a
farmer fire he's like get either a
high-powered uh air rifle or 22 and I
got I have a 22 Ruger now that and shoot
him in the butt and they'll go back and
tell their friends like like this area
will maybe stay away that's mean it
sounds it sounds crazy but it kind of
worked but then like I said then I got
the uh
the uh the great parent reason but I
just don't deal with it I don't it's not
an issue that's great I know I'm not
right yeah I like that and the donkeys
too the donkeys apparently do great I
heard donkeys
it's not that they're super gangster
it's that something evolutionarily like
visually smaller mammal Predators will
see them and they'll be like ah it's not
worth it
I get but I can't see I these donkeys
now granted if they catch you with a
back kick you yeah they will [__] you up
but they're not like vicious animals
like I can't I don't understand how this
has become a thing have you seen that
doctor that beat up that dude I kept
whooping his ass he's like all right
enough's enough oh the breaks if you
catch one their back kick yeah it's
devastating but I just don't see them as
like now are they attached to you yeah
the donkeys
you always say like you don't want to
say who's your favorite kid but to me I
I will walk around on the farm and like
oh you guys are the best come on
like the sheep in the and the and the
goats on this [__] amazing but they
wanted they live their life like the
donkeys genuinely maybe I'm making this
up they just want the food they want me
to feed them but they generally seem
like they want to hang out with me you
know yeah and Comet comedy top tier
animal a [__] donkey yeah how big we
have the mini ones so they're like this
tall do they want to do roosters wake
you up you can't you they do yeah what
time brother uh yeah it's not it's not
crazy like 6 30s because they wake up
when the sun comes up right it seems
like it I also think they I think like a
lot of animals they'll wake up and then
when they're they're like they want
either food or attention that's when
they is that why they start roostering I
don't know because a lot of it I think
is protective or communication because
throughout the day the roosters will
Crow and and also the roosters now the
roosters are badasses some of them
because if you go to like I'll go to
deal with the hens or even feed them the
roosters will fly up and kick me and
[__] like they are protective they you
know there's dude Dan has a friend who
has raccoons you can buy raccoons right
[__] I want a raccoon
it's a problem they're like little cat
dog monkeys with hands yeah they have
like human hands and they'll have the
robber's mask on it all yeah you
probably dealt with it even in an urban
environments like raccoons are not dumb
and they have razors kill my [__]
kill my koi and my [__] Turtles
seriously yes bro
[__] that's brutal yeah they chewed
my Turtles
um what's her name Thelma they chewed
her head off and her little feet off oh
my God who left her there that's my kids
were like where is the turtle Thelma I
was like ah she'd hibernating for the
rest of her life you know [__] bad
liar you have possums too out here
which is crazy because
I really have zero problem shooting
coyote they are a horrible animal
coyotes are horrible animals and they're
kind of [__]
um but I've seen a couple foxes and I'm
like I'm really happy I haven't had to
yet because you are beautiful like
you're a beautiful don't [__] up your
chicken has that problem in California
they all I mean that's the old the old
figure of speech the fox
knows you know like
Alexis or no yeah they'll [__] up your
whole head house I can't have that can't
have snakes [__] off all these is there
anything you miss about La did you win
I'm not one of these guys here to the
country and like [__] on yeah I miss
La a ton I miss what do you miss
uh I mean right off the bat I miss
Dodgers Lakers because my family been
season ticket holders for both since
before I was born yeah so it was a big
Not only was it like I'm a fan it was a
part of my childhood you know Dodger
Stadium was my summer house you know
this is my summer house is that right
yeah oh my dad and I would go to
50 something Dodger games a year and and
probably like every home game and
probably like 20 Laker games on on top
and then every playoff game that was a
home game yeah so you so you missed the
sports I mean you know what I first the
first month here we kind of like I
[__] up no no because the first month
was so much there was so much going on
that I almost didn't have time to think
about it you're just like constantly
grinding you know even before the
animals were there it was like getting
like getting the fencing around all the
acreage to make sure there was no holes
for the coyotes like there's just a
million things what about the front
aspect like you don't have as many
friends out here you're an LA kid Dr
Drew's in Pasadena I
I think it's been a it's been a lot
easier for me than it has my wife uh and
I and I hate to go like the gender slant
thing but I think it's just been easier
to make friends you believe in gender do
I believe it exists yes I do I do you
believe in science
um but but you know like my wife and
maybe it's just lifestyle but you know I
go and train it at the Academy you know
at sheepdog at you know Gracie Mida
training for Tim in those guys I do yeah
and made some friends though and yeah I
make friends and I meet people and I
mean and then you one of my friends went
to see you the other night Kevin yeah
and um I go to the gym and lift weights
and I meet people and like I I built a
network of friends pretty easily it's a
completely different network of friends
like my friends back home growing up
they were my buddies since kindergarten
almost exclusively my friends out here
are like like real life John Wicks you
know it does yeah first it makes me feel
really inadequate like it really does
and I'm not trying to say that just how
[__] it's got like a freezer full of
game meat and all the guns yeah and it's
not even just a bunch of combat medals
and what they say they do it exactly you
know honestly and like you just get a
sentence I had this really badly when I
is probably like 25
I had just been in radio and started to
actually have a life for myself for
being in radio and I was on the Kevin
and Bean Morning Show and it was a
couple years into the second Iraq
invasion
after 9 11. and I was couldn't sleep one
night and I thought I was like my life
pretty meaningless like I make fart
jokes and I get sound collect sound
effects for other dudes to make silly
jokes
and I was like I'm an enlist I'm still
young enough like I could do this and I
could mean something to and my ex-wife
was like I will [__] leave you yeah
you're out of your mind and she but and
so I had this crisis of like well what
when when I when I die hopefully in 50
years uh
what will my life genuinely have meant
and I always have this feeling
especially being around those gentlemen
it's like well you're you really [__]
mean something like your life means
something and and I and I so I I CR I
feel very
um handicapped by that a lot of times
but then I work through it because I was
like well if if I just really commit to
being like a great dad my life means
something hell you know I really commit
to being a great husband important job
my life means something you know so I I
but I do I do feel that you know when
you're around those people they're
talking about like casually talking
about like well the third time I was in
Afghanistan you're like whoa it's crazy
yeah but there's been more benefits than
yeah I do I mean you know what I miss
about La like seriously and uh because
there's amazing Mexican food out here uh
I miss Jewish deli food it's not not a
huge Jewish stronghold in Central Texas
but I I do miss like a really good do
you miss like the energy of La like the
hustle because there's a hustle
mentality I miss the old energy
and I'm not even going with the like
wokeness how old are you now uh 44. yeah
yeah I miss when I was like late in my
teens early 20s where
like a 19 year old 20 year old kid has
this
lofty Hollywood idea of like cultures
meshing and being this like new Fango
there was a time and a place uh through
the mid 90s to the early 2000s we're
like
cholo culture graffiti art surf
skatepunk biker culture was all you know
hip-hop Punk was just this lovely
beautiful goulash and it was you could
feel it and it was [__] awesome and I
missed that and I I you know so being
here doesn't really make me miss out on
it because I don't think it's that way
anymore right no they're no not at all
man I'm I'm jealous of Mike's life I
want to wear a cowboy hat and buy some
boots and get out there in mud yeah get
out there in mud get my hands dirty yeah
some calluses on my hands I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna I'll make the move out here
eventually I'm gonna be working out I
got more [__] to do in L.A where I can't
get done out here yeah and also like
if I was a single man or or my wife and
I didn't have children
it's it's a different thing I mean
you're you're at a different point in
your life right so I would say you
[__] do it but it'd be it's a thing
to uproot your children who have a
friend at work but I got anything and
just be like I got I got a 12 year old
and a 15 year old so I'm there 12 and 15
is actually Peak age of like do you
really want to do that I'm supposed to
be 12. like my son's seven the other
one's three we got another one on the
way you got time as long as long as I do
it before he's nine you're two years
real with the Mexican wife just pounding
you know this is the last one though
she's a hater that's the last one I want
like five but she's a hater man okay how
are you Mexican she's a hair yeah no I
always get [__] because my sister uh she
was keeping it real she has like you
know a million kids and hell yeah I cut
it off at one who is Mexican in your
family or my mom yeah your dad was what
my dad's Irish how Mexican is your mom
like Taco Bell Mexican or like no my
mom's like illegally came here legit
born and raised East Los Boyle Heights
yeah she's pretty Mexican not only
Mexican but like Chicano La yeah hell
yeah for sure
my dad's from Rural Oregon
probably you feel more white though I
you know I was my wife and I are having
this conversation it was um it was very
straight we were having the conversation
about like um non-binary about like you
know I think I was saying that I think a
lot of people
feel like not fully manly at some points
and not fully feminine at some points
both men you know and I was talking I
think it's an LA thing you're liberal
bro no I hey man get out of here I'm a
man you American I'm a man American I'm
a man but but I do think like that at
all you don't ever feel I don't struggle
with that at all you don't ever try that
I have a joke about it like what does it
mean to feel like a man for me it's like
I know how you have to be as a man you
got to make it you gotta you got to wake
up every day this is how a man is I got
all the answers and today's a good day
to die yeah but the truth is I don't
have any answers and I'm always [__]
afraid but I'm not gonna tell anybody
well no so you don't feel like it here's
what I will say no here's what I will
say about it here's what when I feel
particularly masculine uh I will be
encountered with negative emotions or
feelings of sorrow or depression or
worry about something and I and I will
genuinely make that decision I was like
yeah well too [__] bad I'm going but
that's good
I feel like I think I think in the sense
that my wife who is by no means like a
soft person would like to talk about
those feelings yes I'll say this I will
say this about men I would say if I'm
talking broad spectrum women
um benefit a great deal from talking and
and so let's just say
men and women probably have different
needs
emotionally and let me explain men like
to feel significant they like to feel
important they like to feel powerful
they want to feel admired and they'll go
through hell to get to a point where
they have a status that affords them
that when they walk into a room they'll
become Navy Seals they'll freeze they'll
starve they'll they don't need your
psychology succeed their business
whatever whatever it is they don't need
to be talking about their feelings [__]
your feelings bro I want I want to
accomplish give me the gold medal and
give me give me that give me that
trident give me that [__] you know
billion dollars and then we'll talk
about my feelings later on yeah women
connection for women connection is way
more important typically with their
family with their spouse with their is
way more important than feeling
significant it's why when a man walks in
and he's got a gun or a man walks in and
he can do physical damage or a man walks
in and he's got a huge company we notice
men delineate Authority real quick and
we just go which like I want to be kind
of like that's the alpha that's true
like that's there's always exactly why
he was pointing out the overwhelming
majority of of suicides is meant yes
because Classics and I don't think women
genuinely even if they're they're
they're they're
sincere and wanting to understand how
[__] devastating it can be to an
adult male to be embarrassed or publicly
shamed or to fail in a way that makes
you feel uh uh impotent yeah when they
take away your right your ability to
earn a living is that you're creating a
date but when you were all depressed and
stressed out and you text me oh that
sounds like I just get over it get on
the horse just get to work best Frank is
you should be a therapist yeah he goes
snap what do you want from me man I
never am like that but I was he's in
this long time
yeah I feel like [__] today and I was
talking about because some [__] happened
long he goes and he goes up he goes
I get it bro but snap out of it we got
work to do I started laughing so hard
this used to be a therapist but also
what do you want like and we had the
most stressful time of all time on
finding a kid with with all this
financial stuff that's right I didn't
tell Brian about it I just got to work
he's like man you look like [__] I'm
like yeah I'm in the thick of it and I
was like okay
for pointing that out thanks dude I'm in
the thick of it let me get through it we
got through it and it's all good here's
here's it though to get back to your
question about like do you feel more
Maxine or feel more white sometimes it's
both uh sometimes especially in La where
like the culture it's not just like
there's a lot of Mexicans there because
there's a lot of everything in Los
Angeles right the culture of the city is
built on like the framework
of Mexicans and not just Mexican but
like Chicanos like Mexican and you feel
like and I feel very good there's a lot
of Mexican uh influence out here it is
absolutely but it's different it's a
different thing it's a different vibe uh
yeah like like Tejano thing is is I like
it but it's different and like I feel
that and I feel very much in touch with
it sometimes in Mexico you go and you
see like you know like a like an Aztec
uh artifact or something I'm like [__]
yeah you know I watched Apocalypto not
too long ago I was like I'm gonna go
[__] [__] I went outside
that's a good movie yeah hell yeah but
to that point that that's like in in La
it's like this weird like America's the
worst so I've become more like patriotic
more more American where if I'm in Texas
people are like yeah no [__] like yeah
yeah we love them in L.A I'm like oh no
I will storm yeah I'm this close storm
in the castle
come here and I'm softer Texas makes me
a little more liberal because not me
like a contrarian not yeah you're a cook
but no yeah no out here yeah it's
completely hey dude don't call me
or L.A last night Alex Jones uh uh Rogan
Eddie Bravo and and myself and Brendan
and I'm taking on Rogan Alex Jones and
Eddie Bravo on all their his argument
was awful he thinks that sign actually
was talking about Epstein I'm talking
about UFOs I don't buy any of this [__]
and [__] they're coming out it's so
hard too they're coming out so hard and
Brent is not doing anything but he's
sitting at the end of the table he's out
of it he's going like this he [__]
cup tell that [__] and he keeps pointing
at me like that [__] [__] that's
probably more invested than Joe was
because you know what he's no Joe what's
going on so long like I've seen it on
camera where he's just like okay Brian
dude he was like it's like it's like
hearing Bert is in great shape like okay
yeah Brian and his like my laps are just
too big yeah cause I'm one of you guys
will argue with Joe like we're getting
we get Joe and I will get it I would
have loved to have seen like Eddie and
Alex don't bring two-headed Serpent of
uh 10-7 rounds oh he got annihilated
dude I come hard though and then I was
the quarterback me and Rogan will go we
go we Rogan and I used to go at it we'd
have arguments that were so crazy like
at the dinner table my girl his girl and
then he and I be like because he was
like I'm not giving an inch he's not
giving an inch but we still still some
of that but I think one of the reasons
I'm drawn out here because I'm more
politically lined out here where I don't
have to express it so much in La I feel
like I have to defend it all the time
even if someone just asks a simple
question here's a problem you were never
political
my wife's the same way my wife's like
she used to be like uh you know
ignorance is bliss about a lot of uh
social issues with political issues and
now it made her because like you're
constantly everything you do had to be
scrutinized under that microscope and
it's like it's a little bit annoying but
um you're exactly right because when
you're constantly here's a one thing
also it's very important to point out
Los Angeles is [__] huge not only not
only real estate wise people-wise and
Hollywood is not Los Angeles
so when you see Gwyneth Paltrow or
whoever on the news and and or this kind
of Monolithic representation uh of Los
Angeles coming from the Hollywood
Machine trust me LA's mostly truck
drivers and cops and and laborers and
it's just unfortunately there's so much
power and money within the Hollywood
the only person the only like here's a
obviously like a a micro scale but the
only person who could get a better table
at the Palm uh at the old Palm the only
person who could ever think to get in
front of a like a studio exec or like a
big Hollywood a-lister was Jerry Buss
that was it if you weren't Jerry Buss
you had to be some Mogul in Hollywood or
a big celebrity and you get first bid
yes you know yes yeah it's a weird vibe
that's awesome but they're so loud they
influence like the the whole La kind of
perspective it's like so America's like
oh I mean is it changing though is
Hollywood losing its power I think well
my wife and I were just talking about
last night literally like we were
scrolling through like what to watch and
I got her into Shane Gillis right yep
and so she she wasn't familiar and she's
like wow this guy's really he's like
yeah he's he's awesome
and I was telling her the story about
like how Saturday Night Live happened
and then he got fired before he could
even get out there and then but now he's
become like one of the most commercially
and artistically bigger than everybody
right and so I'm like imagine what like
the traditional old machine comedian
actors are thinking like Aquafina must
be at home going like what the [__] do I
have to do if this guy got booted from
Saturday Night Live and you know what
I'm saying I don't have to pick up you
know I'm just thinking of someone who's
Aquafina she's the Asian lady who she's
she's good I I just she's the first one
that came to my mind of like a Hollywood
comic voice you know what I'm saying
like she's all over okay yeah you know
who she is but that's a good thing too
because Back in the Day Shane girls
would have been Uber driver you'd have
no Outlet well there's a whole thing to
that too like where people I use not so
much anymore but people used to ask me
10 years ago like as a radio guy do you
just resent podcasting and I go there's
a sense of like starting on third
thinking you hit a home run you know but
at the same time I remember I was there
I saw it I was not like I'm not like a
part of their crew I'm not trying to
name drop or anything but I grew up on
the east side so in the 90s you saw the
Big Brother Skateboard Magazine dudes
and those were the guys who went on to
become jackass like the jackass crew
okay and that faction of the jackass
crew that wasn't bams from from the
Pennsylvania
and uh so I was in the periphery and I
would see the level of what you had to
do
to get a good skate part in a video and
then Market that video and distribute it
you know
and I I think now kids can be like I
feel like I'm good
Bobby film this and then boom it's on
YouTube and I like the barrier between
creative creativity and feeling like you
have the ability to do it
um you could hear like Corolla talk
about coral and Kim will talk about like
when they were making man show there was
always that feeling of like the weight
of the world is on us to try to get this
to be a thing we have to [__] grind
now I like I genuinely feel whether
you're a musician a comic actor
writer there's there's not that in
just like impossible resistance that
that abstract resistance you feel which
is like good and bad am I gonna be a
real yeah right of course it's good
because you get the market gets flooded
with yes [__] very good stuff you
know but but cream Rises at the top
though yeah sure for sure
[__] we saw a lot of problems tonight
yeah we pretty much solved gun crisis
we've solved yeah Tech's better in L.A
everything dude
Mike um we gotta get Brandon on a plane
that's right go you saved our ass though
we wanted to we we were like we got to
get Mike here because we wanted a guest
and we haven't talked to you in a long
time and uh I'm very happy with one last
question how was your Jiu Jitsu scale of
one to ten you're rolling with some
monsters yes what is you're a purple
belt I am okay now your ghee no ghee are
you comfortable with but like I like oh
yeah I like good fundamentals huh I I
just thought a top game guy bottom game
bottom game New Wave guy what's going on
I've had to become a bottom game guy
like really work on my car because I I
always trained with people who if I was
going to go with people around my size
yeah regardless of skill level I always
felt like well I can muscle them yeah
before but but right when I began not
because I trained with only exclusively
with Orlando Sanchez and like homologous
and they would literally just pass me
around like a crack [__] and then [__]
me up but then when I developed a game I
started to feel like I'm not that
athletic naturally or limber but I could
pass Gardens and I got that game and I
started to work for what now I go over
there and it's just monsters that can
impose my will you know you're not doing
that with Tim Canada exactly Yeah
Tim the worst thing about Tim is not
only will he
[__] he [__] me up
but he tells me about how shitty I am
everywhere yeah he just loves to yeah
I'll like you I'll put him in lockdown I
feel like I'm I'm like scrambling to get
half guard right and I'll just try to
lock it he's like oh you're putting me
in lockdown that's so cute
when I'm here I'll get a text from him
sometimes he'll be like we're training
at 7 30 in the morning you've been
warned I'm like I'm not gonna be there I
could videotape it for me I'll watch you
guys I'll be I'll come and watch yeah I
gotta catch this plan B all right dude
love you guys I'll be in uh Phoenix
Arizona this Friday stand up live two
shows one special night and then it's
Omaha Nebraska and Kansas City yeah come
see me guys come see me at uh in San
Antonio Texas LOL August 24 25 26
September one and two Wise Guys Salt
Lake City and uh we love you
all right
let me thank the drinking Bros I want to
thank the uh also thank the drinking
Bros podcast with Dan Holloway and Ross
Patterson thank you guys you guys are
awesome for letting us use this awesome
amazing it's [__] Brennan up because now
he wants this kind of depth behind
himself